whilst traveling to india the prime
minister has said that he feels that he
has he has nothing to hide
on what basis should we believe him
should we take him at his word given the
the ham-fisted attempts yesterday in the
comments to try and delay this
investigation well we're going to have
multiple opportunities for the prime
minister's word uh to be tested we've
got the the met investigation ongoing
we've committed that once when that's
finished sue gray will complete her
report update her report the primes will
come back to parliament and we've now
got the privileges investigation this is
going to be the most looked at
event possibly since the second world
war why did you try to delay it then i'm
not so sure we did i think there's some
kind of thing around there that we had
the education sector in the deems
sitting where you are yesterday at this
time saying that was exactly what you
were doing i was in the house on tuesday
afternoon when the prime minister was
asked this question directly what did he
want the house to do and he said it's
for the house to decide i think that was
in response to
stella crecy and that's where we got to
i think i think where the confusion was
is that was there was a concern
that the house investigation the
privileges committee would begin an
investigation and inquiry while the met
investigation was ongoing and before the
su grey
report was finally published i think
that confusion was cleared up and it
became clear that they would not
commence that until the met was finished
and the gray report was published so
there was there wasn't an amendment
table there wasn't an amendment pulled
minutes before the vote that well the
president i missed that well the prime
minister has been very clear that
the house can look at this the house
will look at this and he is confident
that when the full context that one of
the other things he said in the house on
tuesday he was frustrated that he
couldn't speak about the context of all
of this put the full facts into the
public domain while these various
processes are ongoing particularly the
met sure he remains confident that when
everyone when people can see the full
context of what happened it will be
clear that he was straightforward he
said to the house in good faith that he
believed the rules were followed people
might take you at face value but not for
the fact that we have been here before
in precisely the same situation this is
owen patterson volume 2. the
conservative party tries to play games
with your partner with asking me with
parliamentary procedure it's clear that
you don't have the support on your own
back benches to go through with it you
pull it you've got egg in your face it's
another crunching gear change another
embarrassing u-turn well i don't accept
that there's any parallel to the
patterson situation that was a situation
where the standards committee had looked
at something it had come to a conclusion
it had made a recommendation and the
house rebelled
just accepting that the house rebelled
an attempt to change that i think people
concede in retrospect that was a mistake
this is a was around how the the sorry
the privileges committee could look at
all of the events around the events in
downing street and i think the question
the only question was around timing and
as i say the prime minister said on
tuesday it'll be for the house to decide
the prime minister said from india he
has nothing to fear nothing to hide he
looks forward to that process he looks
forward to the full facts and crucially
the context coming out i'm sure he's
looking forward to it i think he's
looking forward to this ending i think
he's looking forward to drawing this to
a conclusion for it to be examined fully
so that we can move on to the things
that people are genuinely concerned
about in terms of cost of living energy
price rises all those other things the
situation going on in ukraine the things
that that are inbound towards the
government probably the most challenging
set of circumstances facing a government
in peacetime but let's be absolutely
clear in in letting yesterday's motion
essentially go through on the node the
government has basically admitted this
assertions the prime minister has made
on the floor of the house about the
legality of activities number 10 and the
cabinet office appear to amount to
misleading the house i mean i'm old
enough to remember when cabinet
ministers would step down for
inadvertently misleading the house amber
rudd did so why is there any question
right now of whether of the prime
minister going well there's no question
of the prime minister going not going i
shouldn't say the question is how do we
complete this process how do we get the
facts into the public domain are they
fully examined and how can the prime
minister then speak very candidly about
the context in which events happen
can we just finish this on the motion
because this is very important that was
an opposition day motion opposition
motions happen all the time they're
frequently not voted on the motion
intended to get the events the the
events surrounding what happened in
downing street in front of the committee
that has happened that's the consequence
what the motion said was really nearly
there now there this house believes that
the prime minister's conduct appears to
amount to misleading the house as i said
the ambassador
for less than what the prime minister
has done i mean genuinely i think we are
now at the point where we have to ask
the question under what circumstances
would this prime minister resign what
would it take for him to leave downing
street when beth rigby asked him about
this on the plane on the way out to
india his response is pretty dramatic
not a lot springs to mind well the prime
minister look i was at the
event in downing street the the
statement on tuesday i went to the 22
committee and i listened to the prime
minister explain to the parliamentary
party what the unfinished business of
his government is and what he wants to
deliver for the british people i walked
out with him totally coincidentally he
wasn't talking to me about parties or
inquiries or metropolitan police
investigations he wanted to talk to me
about what was going on in northern
ireland he wanted to talk about the
business of government take for this
prime minister to resign we know that he
won't resign when you know the police
essentially point out that he has broken
the law inside downing streak he won't
resign when senior members of his
cabinet break the law by attending
parties in downing street he won't
resign when the supreme court rules that
he has acted unlawfully in proroguing
parliament and he has misled the queen
we already know of course because it's
being talked about in the papers as well
you're already preparing to to break
international law again by
tearing up the nardin protocol so again
i asked forgive me how are we preparing
to break in tonight
the reports this morning are that we're
getting to the point now in terms of the
northern ireland protocol that we're
going back to the drawing board that you
will pass legislation that will
essentially allow you to tear it up but
the question i have asked well no no
this is very important because you just
said that the government is preparing to
tear up international law regarding uh
the the
that we're preparing to break
international law on the northern iron
protocol if you are talking about the
long-standing uh assertion going back as
far as july last year that we believe
that the circumstance is the threshold
for triggering article 16 a provision of
the treaty of the protocol a provision
of the very protocol invoking that
provision that's not breaking
international law that is applying a
trigger mechanism that is built into the
project brandon lewis in the house of
commons not that long ago suggesting
that you would break international law
again i'll repeat the point domestic
lockheed has broken constitutional law
he has broken international law he is
broken at what point do we have to ask
whether or not this prime minister has
that you have a rule of law you have
asserted that the prime minister has
misled parliament i do not accept that i
believe that the prime minister when he
said to the house of cons at each stage
what he said he believed on the advice
that he was receiving that what he told
in good faith the house of commons was
correct do you think and when it has
emerged
from the question so the price of the
pregnancy the prime minister and the
chance of this check have both received
fixed penalty notices for that event in
the cabinet room
in number 10. both of them have accepted
the fixed penalty notice and both of
them have paid it the prime minister
said to the house on tuesday except that
you don't believe that
he said on tuesday that it did not occur
to him then or subsequently that that
gathering that meeting which was to
discuss very important matters in
relation to the governments the united
kingdom's response to covert was in any
way a breach of the rules however he has
said he accepts the decision that the
metropolitan police have come to which
is a different conclusion and he has
paid one of which answers the question
do you think that the prime minister
broke the law or do you still maintain
that he was ambushed by a cake well i
was trying to make a point and it's not
often you get to write a line in your
obituary live on national television i
was trying to make a point the prime
minister had been outside london he
visited a school i think he did eight or
ten meetings in downing street that
morning before going to hartfordshire to
visit the school he had returned to
start another meeting to which the
chancellor came to the cabinet room to
attend and in between that there was a
spontaneous gathering to wish him a
happy birthday
he was conducting the business of
government
in a sense now that is all um irrelevant
he has accepted the decision of the
police he has paid the fine and he is
now accepting all the inquiries into
this so that the full facts can be
established he has committed that when
the great report sort of fringe opinion
that it's some kind of niche view that
boris johnson has misled the house 80
percent of the british public thinks
he's lying well i do not believe the
prime minister's lied and i believe that
when the full facts are seen when the
context comes out that it will be clear
that the prime minister every time that
he came to parliament was faithful and
genuine and true in what he believed
sixty one percent
tory voters in 2019 do not believe him
what i believe is the prime minister
told the house what he believed to be
the truth in good faith at each stage
and when there has been a development
subsequent subsequent to that new
information he has corrected the record
the other important thing and this is
this is important he has accepted that
the number 10 operation was not working
as it should have done he has
fundamentally restructured his operation
in number 10 to make it much more
transparent and accountable he's brought
in steve barclay as chief of staff david
a formidable political operative as
deputy chief of staff he's got new
parliamentary private secretaries the
operation is now much more streamlined
and effective to serve the prime
minister and the government's agenda how
many more fixed penalty notices can
boris johnson receive without resigning
i mean channel 4's gary gibbon put the
point to the pm yesterday you look at
downing street you look at the number of
fines that have been issued i'm not sure
there's a workplace in the entire
country that has had more fpns handed
out the downing street so how many is
too many
i think look it would be completely
wrong for me as a serving government
minister to try and influence or comment
on a live a police investigation the
police must get on with it i think
they've now gone quiet until after the
local elections although their work will
carry on let's get all the information
out there we want it out there as
quickly as possible because the prime
minister wants to get on with the
business of delivering for the british
people on that amazing
majority that he won just over two years
ago the stuff going on in ukraine
watching the prime minister marshalling
the international community's response
to the events of president putin's
incursion invasion into ukraine seeing
the prime minister representing britain
walking around the streets of downtown
kiev with president zielinski these are
the things the prime minister wants to
get on with and i think those are really
the things the british people ultimately
want to see us get on with